[Music]
[Applause]
NBC and peacock brought you Notre Dame
and navy and uh the Notre Dame
quarterback Sam Hartman joining us on
the program fresh out of a class here
let's go around the room on what class
Sam just got out of
I'm guessing this is grad school that
he's going to Todd what class did Sam
Hartman just get out of I think it's
some type of economic business class oh
no and his AG come on he's not taking
economics why not oh I'm gonna say
ballroom dancing just like Matt Leinart
did uh Seton I was going to say
something to do with money or economics
okay absolutely those are the same Vibe
all right Marvin
I'm gonna say something in journalism
journalism like writing communication I
think Sam wants to be a sportscaster I'm
not sure but I'm going to ask him this
uh Paulie I go high level like a
journalism ethics class ethics ethics
all right let's bring in Sam Hartman
Notre Dame quarterback what class did
you just get out of
they were all very good guesses I love
the uh journalism uh answer that's uh
somebody's done their homework their
research but it was it was an effus
class but it was ethics in sports
um so I Paulie I'm gonna give you credit
thank you I'm gonna give them give you
credit for that congratulations
that's it Sam that's the only reason why
we wanted to have you on and just find
out what class
thank you sounds good I'll see you again
do you want to be a sportscaster I do I
do
um I took some sports journalism classes
back at wake
um and I I really enjoyed it had a great
professor professor katanosa I'm
actually zooming into his class next
week I have a long-standing tradition
with him uh where every year he has a
sports tourism class that I took as a
freshman
um that I come back and they do a mock
interview and
um I I enjoy uh enjoy talking about
sports obviously enjoy playing it and
um I enjoy talking about you know
everything that it has to do with it and
what you do and what everybody does at
this at your level well can I help you
with anything
um I mean shoot if you could find me a
job when I'm done well I'll find you a
job uh maybe an internship how's that
yeah there we go that'd be great
um were you thinking of when you left
wake was there any thought of you going
into the draft
there was there was a lot and I think um
at the beginning of the year uh coming
back to school wasn't in question
um I think five years of college I
thought was a lot
um I felt like you know I was done going
to class done being in a college setting
and was ready to you know take a stab at
the NFL and
um you know thankfully I had another
opportunity and really the coveted year
was kind of this
um weird thing that that everyone has
taken advantage of or either not and
um really towards the end of the year
it's actually a funny story the main
reason it came up is my brother who
looks similar to me as brothers do
um is in med school down at Florida and
he was walking around and somebody
thought it was me
um and just tweeted it out and that's
the power of social media and it kind of
became this like oh Sam's transferring
to University of Florida it's a done
deal and I'm like I'm sitting in a wake
meeting room like what are they talking
about and
um so that kind of sparked the Curiosity
for us and this process of like hey you
know there might be um you know
potential for this being a legitimate
you know idea yeah and then we just kind
of went through and once the season was
over looked at the prospects the
different
um schools and felt like Notre Dame was
the best fit
um how many schools were recruiting you
once they found out that you might be
open to this there was quite a few I
mean any you can think of any college
um that needed a quarterback or was in
need was was reaching out um you know
give me for instance give me a couple of
schools here
um you know Florida was one
um uh Auburn was another one
um I mean at the time there's a little
bit of Alabama but I mean it was all it
was all strategic in my way of just
knowing that it kind of came down to at
the time
um the offense uh in place here at at
Notre Dame and and the school
um and what it represents and and then
the other side was just the NFL
component of like do I want to go back
and like you started with take classes
again and
um and risk injury or whatever you want
to call it I think that was
um really the the two sides did you see
Joe Montana while you're in Ireland I I
got a thumbs up from him probably one of
the coolest moments in my life he was
walking by
um that was uh that was surreal I got I
when we were practicing they were
running through all the different
announcements they were going to do in
the game and I heard His Kind of big
announcement like there's if he's here
that's going to be pretty special and he
was walking by when we were going over
the last drive and got a little thumbs
up I was like all right you know that's
a that's a cool moment I'll never forget
have your teammates ask you to buy them
beer yet
um you know I it's been it's been a you
know I'm 24 at this point so I mean I
think at some point I might over have uh
you know there's there's I I can't admit
or deny
um any of those I believe this how about
that okay I
often just being 24 come up for you
it's way way too much I think that
there's a that's the I'm the old man and
milk are our Long Snapper just turned 24
today so uh or yesterday
um and it was actually my brother's
birthday yesterday he just turned 26 so
happy birthday Joe
um but so now he's 24 so I'm not the
only one but it's it's a big one I mean
I think that
um you know my age shows sometimes with
some of the freshmen and just what they
do and what they talk about but um it's
it's fun to be the old guy what's like
Stetson Bennett
why not I mean if you're not in a rush
to go to the NFL and you enjoy the
experience and you're playing at a high
level being a Notre Dame quarterback
pretty good gig
it's not it's not too bad it's it's a
it's a hard gig to turn down I'll tell
you that we're talking to uh Sam Hartman
Notre Dame starting quarterback had uh
four touchdown passes the necklace has
to come up your age and that you have a
necklace that's made out of what
it's made out of my own rib that my mom
created uh yeah it's a quite a quite an
interesting uh headline right there that
people like to grab
um but yeah it's a part of part of the
story where is it it is at my house
right now it was it was in Dublin
Ireland with me and um it was around
when I was traveling around but it is
back back home and you know it'll
probably appear on the the game day the
game day walks and a little bit of
warm-ups but it's a little sharp so I'm
a little nervous you know I might try to
go back to where it belongs uh but it
was uh it's a it's a cool feature piece
it's something I'm proud of something
that almost a little weird and obscure I
know that and I understand that but
um just kind of like a scar or a tattoo
you know it's something that I can
always remember back to and and lean on
I got a side hustle for your mom I mean
other people may want to make you know
necklaces out of this
you know I don't know if the uh the
money gets tight she might have to uh
get back and get back into work and that
might be it what was the feeling like
put me in to you with the Notre Dame as
opposed to last year at wake the the
pressure uh that it came along or comes
along with that
um I mean I think on the field it's all
the same I mean I think you're you know
you want to perform at your highest
level you want to be the best that you
can possibly be and I think
um the similarity comes from just the
team I think uh I've been really lucky
and just have had some great teams
um and great teammates and great coaches
that you want to play for
um I mean and again you I don't know a
quarterback or a player whoever wants to
go out and not perform at their highest
level so I would say it's very similar I
think
um the cool thing about this past
weekend was just the the scene
um of where we were obviously in Dublin
Ireland
um playing against Navy and old
traditional you know rivalry that um has
been built for longer than I've been
alive and
um and I think that was probably the the
more pressure of just
um being out there a new offense new
offensive coordinator new teammates and
just
um you know making sure that everything
was working and operating smoothly did
you like Notre Dame at all growing up
I really doubt was actually I grew up a
um and I don't I don't want to get in
trouble for this but I grew up a huge
Michigan fan I was I was a Michigan fan
my entire life until I got to college
wow
uh so you hated Notre Dame probably
growing up I did I wasn't I really and
like I it was really Ohio state that I
wasn't a fan of like it just based on my
Michigan status and
um but yeah I was not not a huge one but
again once once once they stopped
recruiting me I was like okay well let's
Wake Forest and then let's Notre Dame oh
Michigan stopped recruiting you well
they never really did I was stopping it
was probably
it's gonna stop
did Ohio state recruit you no I was uh I
only had three offers coming out of
college I had uh Wake Forest UNC
Charlotte and Elon
um so I was uh not the not the biggest
star out there okay well now you can
take care of Ohio State in a couple of
weeks
that is that is true but right now it's
uh we're on one of this week and trying
to go 1-0
well it was fun to watch and uh congrats
on your debut there and thanks for
joining us and uh if we can help down
the road with uh you becoming a better
broadcaster I've seen there's a clip
that was sent to me this morning and
it's you reading off teleprompter and uh
it didn't go well Sam
yeah I think is uh Mr Gore and Dave
goren's uh class that was I remember
that it just happened to be Dave goren
who is uh runs the uh sportscaster Hall
of Fame who sent that to me I think I
appreciate thank you Professor Gordon I
appreciate that you know what I'll make
sure and I'll never respond to him again
so just you got to work on those things
and yes sir reading reading off a
teleprompter you have to act as if you
know present yourself that you're not
moving your head or your eyes and you
stare right into the middle of the the
camera and try to take it'd be like
seeing the whole field as a quarterback
you got to see the whole prompter there
and don't move your eyes don't move your
head and you just want to be very casual
when you deliver not read
yes sir I appreciate the info and I'm
gonna next time I'm in that situation
I'll be thinking of this combo so thank
you all right thank you Sam good to talk
to you yes sir go on Irish that's Sam
Hartman Notre Dame starting quarterback
uh uh he threw 77 touchdowns I think
over his last two seasons at Wake Forest
he got a I think 100 touchdown passes so
you get somebody like that running your
offense and that's a big difference for
that uh that offense